we all have our role to play there are  machines in this world but now like us  you and I have no mother a father where  Allah outnumbered  we have to be smarter than them  where they'll find us  tell us  I'm gonna show this world to our Lea's  why'd she bring you back  Ford made each of us for a reason  even Dolores  [Music]  I came back to find someone who could  help me  someone's strong enough to stop her if  it comes to that these violent delights  have violent ends  we meet again  George nowhere  don't know why but I know we meet again  some sunny day  I thought your world would be so  different from mine smiling there's no  difference at all this time just like  you always  - Babu spies flow take much to bring it  all crashing down  [Music]  you  [Music]  you